c'est la première réunion publique
organisée dans les yvelines depuis
l'élection de valérie pécresse au
congrès les républicains
c'était en décembre dernier et ce 3
février nous sommes à la mairie du
vésinet pour suivre l'événement
événements qui se déroulent en votre
présence michel barnier bonsoir choix
j'écoute merci vous est conseillé france
et europe donc dans le monde auprès de
valérie pécresse est donc l'objectif
c'est soutenir bien sûr la candidate du
parti elle l'est républicain à la
présidentielle mais comment on va
s'exprimer auprès des yvelinois ce soir
d'abord je suis ici au vésinet
l'invitation avec sandra du blanche qui
est l'une de mes amis qui travaillent au
côté très très proche d'eux alaï
pécresse qui est une élue compétentes
respecter dynamique et donc j'ai très
volontiers je vais apporter un
témoignage de soutien de confiance parce
qu'elle va être candidate pour être
l'une des député des yvelines au mois de
juin prochain et naturellement ensemble
et avec tous beaucoup d'élus
parlementaires sénateurs élus locaux et
beaucoup de militants nous sommes aux
côtés de valérie pécresse pour qu'elle
devienne la première femme présidente de
la république française ça sera notre
honneur et notre audace que de proposer
ce choix aux français et puis je vais ce
soir non pas faire de la propagande sera
qu'une campagne électorale c'est un
moment de rencontre confrontation de
parfois de polémique mais aussi un
moment de pédagogie d'écouté de dialogue
de jouer comme je suis aux côtés de
valérie pécresse et ça ne surprend
personne en charge des questions de
politique étrangère d'europe de sécurité
extérieure parler des grands enjeux qui
sont importants pour notre vie
quotidienne qui nous concerne qu'il
s'agisse du changement climatique qui
surgissent de l'europe au moment où il
ya un risque de conflit en ukraine qu'il
s'agisse de la sécurité de la lutte
contre le terrorisme avec ce qui se
passe au au mali il ya tellement de
sujets qui qui sont des enjeux globaux
autour de nous dans le monde tel qu'il
est il faut bien regarder les yeux
ouverts et qui ont des conséquences dans
notre vie quotidienne dont j'aurais dire
un mot deux de ses grands enjeux et dire
la manière dont valérie pécresse volet
déjà engagé un échange donc auprès des
yvelinois d'ailleurs le département à
les yvelines
un département largement de droite ce
sont les terres de valérie pécresse un
terrain qui est con qui selon vous a pas
d'élections gagnées d'avancé a pas de
conquête qui tombe du ciel nous et
valérie pécresse le ch est bien de vous
regarder la l'opiniâtreté la ténacité
qu'elle met dans cette campagne
aujourd'hui je vous parlais était hier
soir sur le charles de gaulle en
méditerranée est en corse je serai avec
elle samedi elle elle fait une campagne
très sérieuse de respect et de dialogue
de respect de dialogue avec les citoyens
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'élections gagnées
d'avancé
des sondages
est ce que vous seriez vous expliquer
pourquoi
sondage c'est une photographie à un
moment donné voyez bien que lé pécresse
dérange beaucoup elle dérange le premier
public qui n'a pas envie d'avoir une
femme en face de lui au deuxième tour
elle dérange monsieur ou madame le pen
qui craignent d'être empêchés d'être au
deuxième tour donc je vois bien les que
les attaques se concentraient parfois
violentes parfois pas très digne ou pas
très correct néanmoins elle tient sa
route elle fait ses propositions une par
une jour après jour et elle résiste on
voit dans les sondages donc je pense
qu'à partir de cette base de confiance
qui est pas seulement celle des
républicains et du centre c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'électeurs je pense qu'elle va
monter au point d'être qualifié pour le
2e tour est très liée aux 2 au 2e tour
en tout cas aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'échangé auprès enfin en tout
cas sur les grandes thématiques auprès
des yvelinois ses fins moi je pense
qu'il faut respecter les citoyens faire
appel à l'intelligence c'est pas des
slogans dont ils ont besoin chacun des
acteurs c'est comment il a envie de
voter vivons mieux qu'en 2006 on connaît
bien l pécresse parce qu'elle est d'ici
mais je crois que c'est important de
savoir qu'elle a une équipe constituée
d'ailleurs d'hommes et de femmes qui
était une des opinions différentes au
mois de décembre moi même j'étais
candidat à la primaire on fait
simplement ce qu'on a dit on avait dit
qu'on serait derrière celle ou celui qui
serait en tête et en fait ce qu'on a dit
donc pourquoi je suis content d'être
avec elle quelles sont les prochaines
étapes clés finalement à venir dans
cette course à la présidentielle
d'accord on continue c'est la fin d'une
campagne très courte qui est en état on
pense au 10 avril donc on a
moins de deux mois donc c'est un faux
courts et longs pour aller dans tous les
départements y compris l'outre-mer il ya
un grand meeting 13 février à paris au
zénith où tout le monde est invité et ça
sera l'occasion pour les pécresse de
donner la confirmation de cette
dynamique est avec elle présentait son
programme donc voilà et ensuite on
enchaînera toutes les réunions jusqu'au
10 avril et après pour le deuxième tour
aussi vous êtes vous êtes plutôt serré
vous parlait déjà du deuxième tour il
pour vous donc on sera au deuxième tour
où est encore calme du travail à faire
oui il ya toujours du travail à faire
mais on travaille pour être avec valérie
pécresse présent au deuxième tour et
offrir il s'agit de cela une alternance
une alternative possible que ce duel
annoncé fabriquer davance par l'extrême
droite le pen ou zemmour ou par le
président sortant monsieur macron ce
duel qu'ils veulent d'entre eux comme si
il était propriétaire de ce deuxième
tour eh bien on démontre que ça va pas
se passer comme ça mais que valérie
pécresse porte une proposition au nom de
la droite républicaine et du centre et
beaucoup d'autres électeurs pour les
gens différents de l'alternance moi je
pense qu'on a besoin d'une femme
aujourd'hui la personne république on a
besoin d'une alternance eh bien écoutez
c'est sur ces mots qu'on va qu'on va se
laisser merci beaucoup michel vergnier
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle un
conseiller français europe dans le monde
auprès de valérie pécresse est on le
rappelle prochaine échéance le 10 avril
date du premier tour des élections
présidentielles